the french police came early in the
morning dozens of vans here to shut down
a camp that's grown into a home for
maybe 1500 men women and children
it didn't take long people forced out
and behind them a mixture of rubbish and
possessions
this was the french police proving they
do
take migration seriously
as we filmed rawas was returning still
wet from a failed attempt to cross the
channel his tent and possessions all
gone
terrible it's not just coming back i
came back from the middle of the sea
now i don't know what i'm gonna do
tonight
look that was my home
did you have things temporary home i
never wanted to be here
yeah
i live here
it was certainly eye-catching but was
this anything more than that
making life uncomfortable probably won't
stop these people from trying to cross
the channel
so this makeshift camp has now been
cleared out but all the people who are
staying here do need somewhere else to
sleep the night and plenty of them are
dotted around the woods and empty
buildings just near here they're trying
to stay one step ahead of the police and
one migrant predicted to me earlier that
this camp will be back in use and full
of people within a week or two
a month ago we filmed groups of iraqi
kurds carrying a boat down the beach in
cali to head to the uk
but this is where the journey begins for
many of the kurds we met today
forcing their way through the fraught
border between belarus and poland
this man survived the journey despite
beatings from guards and freezing cold
he says he's lucky to be alive you may
die
it's very possible to die
in the jungle
please don't come
is that what you would say to people
isn't yeah do not come do not make the
journey don't come from the belarus
and poland border it's very difficult
please
stay in kurdistan
don't come
as nightfalls the migrants expelled from
the camp gather round a fire they spent
two hours collecting the wood
but it is deemed unsafe
as we watch the police come over in
force
and in a moment
the fire has gone
these people are moved on
this is a miserable cold night for
miserable cold people and yet they do
seem determined to get to britain
regardless of politicians or police
adam parsons sky news northern france